m
ils étaient quelques centaines des
classes moyennes pour protester contre
les impôts les abus du fisc et les
technocrates
une centaine de personnes ont défilé ce
matin dans les rues de cayenne et
déposer une motion dans les diverses
institutions du département sommes
descendus pour protester quand
augmentation des taux d'imposition
quel 64 pour la ville de cayenne 42,5
pour le département de la guyane et 22%
pour la région alors pour vous c'est
trop c'est trop
trop c'est trop effectivement
les contribuables briançonnais ont
désormais leur emploi à l'entrée de la
ville
le peu d'humour qui leur reste ils s'en
servent donc pour exprimer leur
inquiétude face à la décision de la
chambre régionale des comptes
d'augmenter leurs impôts pendant la
pression qu'on supprimer tous les côtés
on paye encore plus et on soit encore
moins et la dent nous on ya pour rien
[Applaudissements]
déjà célébré aux etats-unis en allemagne
cette journée de libération du
contribuable a lieu en france le 16
juillet une date issu d'un simple
rapport sur 100 francs gagné 54 francs
atterrissent dans les caisses de l'état
puis d'un jour sur deux du travail des
français est accaparée par les impôts de
dépenses de l'état le collectif contre
la vie chère de guyane lui non plus ne
baisse pas les bras
lycéen socioprofessionnelles
transporteurs pêcheurs agriculteurs
associations plus de deux milliers de
personnes pour une fois de plus dire non
à la vie chère
[Musique]